okay so should I refer to you as New
York Times best-selling author Channing
Tatum or just chanting it's just Chan is
fine yeah yeah did you ever think that
you would be doing this no absolutely
not that's so cool I didn't think I'd be
doing any of this I would love there to
be someone to go and find any one of my
English teachers and ask them if I was
the least likely to be published much
less uh a New York Times bestseller they
would probably guarantee you that why do
you say that I could barely get I could
barely pass I could barely like string
together like a like a fully formed
sentence so maybe you should reach out
to an Old English teacher I would love
to they would be like what I doubt they
even remember me I was you know Florida
seriously I have a Philly Channing
Tatum's a little memory I don't know I'm
not sure about this you battle dyslexia
oh yeah correct oh yeah what brings you
the greatest joy in Reading you get to
kind of like do voices and whatnot but
with my daughter I would have to all
these voices and she was like this lame
dad can you just can you just read it
normal and I'd be like I'm like giving
the best performance of my life right
now you've said that this might be your
favorite book so far why is that it's
really it's it's a little more complex I
remember a story of of my daughter's
very first like big kind of like yucky
feeling lie what was that like she stole
a little toy car uh from from school and
and she was just sick about it and I
could tell something that was a little
different then all of a sudden just like
full tears and I was like I I need to
tell you something but I'm afraid and
I'm gonna I'm gonna get kicked out of
school and go you're gonna call the
police and like it was it was just like
a whole fear spiral and then she told me
and I could just see like the whole
weight lift off of her like just like
just the like the yeah she just became
like a little like her again you know
isn't that just amazing like as a father
I can only imagine the evolution of
little Everly I mean are you learning do
you feel like just as much as she is
along the way I'm probably I might be
learning more I feel like the book
releases perfectly timed the book's
coming out the next day is Everly's 10th
birthday double digits dude what are you
doing to celebrate uh we just went to
Six Flags so we kind of did it early are
you ready for those teenage years no I
don't think anybody is ready for the
teenage years honey I've heard it's like
aliens come down and just snatch your
kid away and then bring it back like you
know around 22 or so give or take yeah
so good luck
go with us through those younger years
into teenage years into young adults um
I think for maybe the books she might
stay the same age
um but we'll see with the movies we're
hopefully gonna do a little animated TV
series so we'll see with those you know
I don't know well do you run ideas by
Everly hey hun when we do like little uh
collabs and we make tutus and clothes
and things like that she gets to decide
I mean I feel like on the gram she's
probably dressed you herself from time
to time oh yeah yeah yeah yeah most
times then I'm on the ground really yeah
she's very she's going to Fashions
Fashion Camp uh this coming week no way
he's a little designer well you designed
one heck of a fort for her I'm a good
four Builder I can do that that's one of
my skills we've done draw Bridges we've
done moats we've done all different kind
of things OMG my childhood dreams right
there
[Music]